si je peux up normalement je vois le
live donc c'est ok on va bien il est 10
heures du coup parce que soyons peuvent
en faire un pays où il est il est 10
heures donc dis pas ce que je veux mais
encore une fois c'est la première fois
que je suis en live du cloud voilà faut
que j'essaie de commandeur de
perfectionner la technique mais voilà on
va pouvoir y aller je pense puisque par
contre pourquoi j'aime bien
on sait le figra ça c'était plutôt une
mauvaise idée donc merci d'être là déjà
et puis si vous regardez ça lui plaît
évidemment l'a77 vidéo sera disponible
ensuite par sommes sûrs sur ma chaîne
youtube pour pouvoir le regarder ensuite
si nécessaire donc n'hésitez pas à me
dire dans ma finca me permettre des
questions si on avait pendant le pendant
la représentation
je pense que ça va durer je vais essayer
de faire durer ce sera aux commandes
d'une heure sur ne pas être trop pénible
de 6 at il ya des gens éventuellement
qui veulent intervenir
n'hésitez pas à laisser un message et
puis j'essaierai de répondre aux
questions j'essaierai faire une pause
entre chaque article pour pouvoir
pouvoir seulement vous laisser le temps
de poser des questions si en a si on a
pas je serai je vois juste un petit peu
de il sert de faire une pause et fier et
puis repartira après donc l'idée de ce
live donc sa belle à la longue parce que
je vais traiter du coup de trois
articles différents mais trois articles
qui seront contraints de circuler aux
mêmes autour d'un même autour d'un même
sujet et aujourd'hui j'ai parlé j'ai
décidé de parler du coût du sujet dès de
l'intelligence artificielle et dont les
impacts psychosociaux
alors les impacts psychosociaux c'est un
terrain peu galvaudé c'est pour dire en
gros
qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce que
l'indiquait ce que l'intelligence
artificielle dans certains de nos usages
va provoquer chez nous va provoquer en
tant qu'individu et puis va pas
provoquer
sur un plan plus global politique
sociale voilà donc c'est les thématiques
c'est les thématiques qu'on va aborder
qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui donc
évidemment l'idée c'est que avant de
pouvoir de pouvoir comment leur parler
des différentes des différents des
différents sujets différents articles
donc c'est des articles lons pour ce qui
s'appelle à la longue dans des articles
longs et épais pose le pied chez piocher
pardon dans différents journaux dans
différents magazines en ligne et jeux de
rôles est particulièrement pertinent
pour parler de telle ou telle sujet et
du coup le but avec les regrouper un
petit peu pour pouvoir tirer des
conclusions de ce qu'ils disent 2
pourquoi ils le disent et puis pourquoi
je les ai choisis parce que je les ai
trouvés potentiellement intéressant donc
pour commencer on va essayer de se
définir ensemble de ce que ces
intelligences artificielles et on va
voir qu'intelligents sortir en soi c'est
déjà une première
jeudi déjà une bêtise quand je dis
intelligence artificielle parce que on
va voir que l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un terme sa faim rappelle le
prénommé sahara d'ailleurs spécial c'est
le premier péché des professionnels de
2,2 qui ont qui nous demande baptisé
cette ce fonctionnement de l'ordinateur
puisque cette intelligence on la met
forcément parallèle avec l'intelligence
humaine
or et bien cette intelligence elle n'a
pas grande chose du même puisqu'elle n'a
pas d'emploi du fonctionnement
finalement humain même si par faire
qu'un principe on va voir quelle va
essayer d'imiter le cerveau humain pour
pouvoir fonctionner je voulais la
définition telle et telle qu'elle est
vue de ce que c'est l'intelligence
artificielle c'est le concept qui permet
à l'ordinateur de marché vaguement comme
le cerveau
donc c'est il va y avoir des mises en
place des heuristiques c'est-à-dire bbb
des processus qui vont permettre de
faire en sorte qu'on va pouvoir inité la
façon dont nous on pense qu'on va voir
que est une vraie différenciation entre
la façon de blue on pense des choses
simples quand on arrive à faire que
l'ordre ne tardent pas à faire et puis
des choses plus compliquées que
l'ordinateur parvient à faire mais que
nous on n'arrive pas à réaliser dans ce
cas là il ya une autre notion importante
que je voulais préciser vite faire avant
de commencer c'est celle d'une machine
learning et donc le match énorme donc
c'est dans le cadre de l'intelligence
artificielle
le machine learning c'est le processus
qui va permettre à l'ordinateur
d'engranger des données ont voulu
nourrir de la donner peu importe quelle
donnée par exemple des données sur des
individus ou des photos éventuellement
1000 photos par exemple d'une chaise et
avec un algorithme précis l'intelligence
artificielle va pas revenir avec ses
1000 photos de chaise a reconstitué à
essayer de définir dans ses paramètres à
elle qu'est ce qui est une chaise alors
que potentiellement pour nous en tant
qu'humain en tant qu'enfant par exemple
on n'a pas forcément devoir besoin de
voir mille objets pour pouvoir se faire
une idée du d'un talent obligations
montre un enfant
tiens voilà société une bouteille tout
ceci est une chaise il va très vite
avoir l'intuition de ce que c'est une
chaise et pour pouvoir voir une chaise
complètement différente et identifier
quand même comme chaise l'ordinateur lui
ne parvient pas à faire ça en tout cas
est par exemple très difficilement à le
faire on voit aussi que la machine est
capable de mieux faire avec le machine
learning notamment les choses qu'un
humain par exemple on voit le cas des
machines autonomes les machines
autonomes sont capables par exemple les
voitures autonomes sont capables parfois
de mieux anticiper un certain certains
certains obstacles certainement
certaines difficultés
certes certains dangers
mieux que l'humain mais par contre
l'humain ce qu'il est capable de faire
par contre c'est de conduire dans à peu
près toutes les situations dans tous les
chemins chose que la machine va avoir du
mal à faire mais on voit qu'il ya une
difficulté pour la maxime de s'adapter à
différentes situations d'engranger de
nouvelles de nouvelles façons de
conceptualiser un petit peu le monde
mais après une fois que sert une fois
que c'est en place la rapidité de calcul
la force de calcul de la machine va
permettre de faire ça parfois mieux que
l'humain m
je voudrais juste faire une parenthèse
avant de commencer aussi on va parler
des réseaux sociaux donc nécessaire on
va parler de google de facebook et on va
parler aussi du coup d'amazon d'apple et
microsoft ce qu'on appelle les gars
femmes et dont j'avais besoin
pourquoi n'utilise pas ce terme ce que
j'aurais pu utiliser plusieurs fois dans
le bon temps dans l'intérim d'un toit et
j'ai choisi de ne pas le faire ou alors
si je le fais du coup vous pourrez me
reprendre c'est que je fais absolument
pas exprès les gars pam s'est du coup
google amazon facebook apple microsoft
et certains génériques qui on appelle ce
dernier les big five les cinq grandes
entreprises c'est les entreprises qu'on
voit là qu'à mendier un peu big pharma
pour voir toutes les tout l'institut le
commandant de tout principe des
laboratoires en afrique en général qu'à
femme ça va ça va représenter toutes les
entreprises informatiques
or moi j'en prends futile map a pas
utilisé ce terme là et à floréal au fur
et à mesure que j'ai lu sur cette
thématique là du coup ça va toujours
perturbé m et effectivement que
justement tu avais passé d'accord avec
vous sur le fait que c'est pas très
pertinent selon les sujets par exemple
si on parle de l'urbanisme
est ce que c'est bien de parler des gars
femme dans la mesure où elles changent
la façon de par exemple pour qu'on soit
la ville mais du coup pourquoi on ne
parle pas des herbiers de vie parce que
ça change plutôt nos villes si on parle
de déplacement
d'accord on parle de google amazon
facebook voilà mais est ce que ce serait
pas plus pertinent pour des grosses
entreprises de parler par exemple du
beurre ou de parler de tesla par exemple
pour aux hasards voilà donc le terme d'
affamer un peu et on va voir assez
complet il s'y fait une généralité du
coup je n'aime pas utiliser et donc du
coup voilà je voulais juste préciser ça
je crois que c'est intéressant de 2,2 de
voile de se poser la question de
pourquoi on utilise d'autres termes la
haye ce qu'il apparaisse ans trop
générique et du coup est ce qu'il
faudrait pas le bannir de notre de notre
utilisation des ce terme là c'est une
question que je me pose est que vous
posez donc le programme arctique
c'est donc c'est des carènes à eau qui a
été publiée dans le mi6 technology
review d'anglais en haïti c'est le
massachusetts institute of technology et
à boston et qui est connu pour former
les meilleurs ingénieurs américains et
pourrait être une des écoles si ce n'est
l'école la plus la plus connue pour les
ingénieurs aux états unis donc c'est
elle qui va former justement les
ingénieurs très performant qui vont
ensuite aller travailler justement chez
chez ces grandes entreprises du
numérique
donc là on va parler de facebook on va
voir que les réseaux sociaux c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on va ce combat
se on va se concentrer
j'aurais bien envie d'appeler jean rémy
peut appeler cette cette présentation un
des gentils fille ciel par les réseaux
sociaux impacts psychosociaux mais on va
voir que ça c'est peut-être un peu
limitatif et on va déborder un petit peu
de ce cas voilà donc du coup voilà j'ai
décidé de faire un peu plus large et
donc l'article sa peine a ou facebook
get elected springs et donc comment
facebook est devenu du coup addict est
devenu accro au fait de diffuser des
mauvaises informations
c'est une question se pose car elle a eu
et qu'elle va se poser suite notamment à
la sphère de cambridge et leyti kâ et
pour ceux en fait elle va se elle va se
concentrer sur l'interview d'un type qui
s'appelle joaquin qui dialoguent ndella
qui est le directeur
l'intelligence artificielle gérant
permet notamment de l'intelligence
artificielle et chez facebook et on va
voir qu'il a eu un rôle important dès le
départ pour concevoir intelligence
artificielle chez facebook
on va voir quelles sont ses implications
quelles sont les questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui
et puis
en quoi finalement de remettre en
question la façon dont facebook nous
présente de l'information
comment elle nous en parle et
éventuellement comment nous on peut hein
peut s'accommoder de sept de ses
algorithmes et peut-être les remettre en
question face aux informations qu'on
peut qu'on peut recevoir
voilà donc jusqu'où ça va parler de
machine learning comme on l'a dit
comment la machine apprend on va se
focaliser sur le personnage de jean
etienne finir comme des lapins
et quel est le rôle de l'antigang
artificielle de facebook sur les
positionnements politiques
ça peut avoir des impacts évidemment
puisque on est beaucoup à utiliser et de
façon massive
ça sent important et est il possible
d'agir sur le comportement de cet arrêté
angers l'artificiel ou est ce que c'est
devenu trop gros et trop important avec
trop d'enjeu pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
le réguler pour pouvoir éventuellement
il peut imposer des freins si si si
nécessaire donc je prends un peu de
chaleur et du premier match aux clients
donc évidemment c'est une question c'est
une question politique donc en fait le
questionnement que cette journaliste de
l'ats il arrive après l'homme ce qu'on
appelle le scandalise le scandale dans
le scandale de cambridge analytique est
donc cambridge a ainsi cassé une c'est
une firme a été créée en juillet 2014
et c'est une fille c'est une firme en
fait que on va retrouver ensuite au
coeur d'un scandale qui va arriver
justement à partir de 2018 notamment
et donc c'est une firme de conseil et
c'est une firme de conseil est une firme
une agence d'influents ce qu'elle dit
car on peut appeler ça comme ça qui va
être au coeur parce qu'on a le mondial
dans la mesure où on va l'accuser en
collaboration avec facebook notamment en
utilisant les données de facebook
d'avoir influé à la fois pour le vote
oui au breakbeat et également pour
l'élection de donald trump
c'est un scandale qui va être être mis
en exergue et qui va aller poser la
question justement grand public de dans
quelle mesure le l'intelligence
artificielle de facebook influence notre
jugement
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire contre ça et
éventuellement et dans laquelle mesure
justement des firmes privées peuvent
utiliser ça pour faire valoir
ensuite des intérêts un peu plus
important puisque c'est pas n'importe
quoi effectivement que soit le que ce
soit le l'élection d'un homme chuck ou
le leu auprès de sites
c'est quand même des événements qui ont
à chaque fois bousculé de façon
extrêmement importante
la politique internationale donc ce
scandale va donner du coup en 2002 à une
condamnation du coup à septembre à
l'injection de diriger l'entreprise pour
le alexander knicks qui est donc le
patron de cambridge analytiques pour ce
qu'ils appellent un comportement
dépourvu d'éthique et effectivement on
peut se douter que utilise des données
personnelles d'individus pour aller
influent influer sur une décision
démocratique c'est effectivement un
euphémisme que de dire qu'ils
comportement est dépourvu d'éthique
ces éléments là ils ont été reconnus
pour par par par facebook est
aujourd'hui facebook dit qu' ils
cherchent par plusieurs méthodes
allez rationaliser son indigence
difficiel pour éviter la diffusion de
nouvelles informations l'influencent sur
les débats démocratiques
c'était plus une espèce d'équité entre
les différentes opinions politiques mais
on va voir que non seulement c'est
extrêmement compliqué à mettre en place
et en plus que facebook a pas inventé la
formidable à le faire ça ne s'est pas du
tout une thèse une thèse complotiste
c'est simplement que ça s'oppose à une
donnée fondamentale qui est donc là il
dit quand on est dans le business donc
c'est tina brown qui est qui est
justement une non ce n'est pas tenable
enlacé par d'origine me suis trompé en
plus c'est harry farid pardon je ne
regarde pas caramba c'est intenable
je me suis content et c'est harry farine
qui est pas un professeur justement
médias et ans et en politique et qui dit
que quand on est dans le business
de maximiser l'engagement de maximiser
la participation des individus à un
réseau social par exemple on n'est pas
intéressé par la vérité
on n'est pas intéressé dans le fait de
blessé dans le fait de diviser dans le
fait de créer des conspirations des
complots et même que tous ces
éléments-là qui serait nocif à la
démocratie ce sont nos amis parce que on
va voir que plus une information va être
choquant plus une information va être
interpellante plus elle va nous nous
faire lever d'une chaise un plus c'est
une information qui va être intéressante
apprendre à prendre en compte qui va
être intéressant pour le réseau social
parce qu'il va amener du coup les
individus a plus à les posséder
commentaires éventuellement réagir et
que du coup forcément ça va donner plus
de visibilité à la plateforme facebook
et donc du coup plus de visiteurs des
visiteurs plus longtemps et donc du coup
pour des firmes comme facebook qui sont
basés sur la publicité plus cela peut de
plus la possibilité de calais et
évidemment des publicités ce qui on va
voir alliés et la commande et le la
dualité principal c'est-à-dire la
volonté d'engager et la volonté de ne
pas polarisé les dissensions politiques
on va voir que ce sont 2,2 du coup deux
concepts qui s'affrontent qui ce qui ce
qui se combattent et qui ne sont
fondamentalement du coup pas compatir
donc joaquin dialogue comme des lacets
ça je prononce dans ce moment j'espère
pour les hispaniques vous me direz il va
être du coup me après ces scandales là à
la tête du ce qu'il appelle le faire
donc faire ça veut dire équitable en
anglais et qui est un laboratoire de
recherche fondamentale je fais ouvre
pour essayer de mettre en place
justement des règles éthiques sur cet
algorithme qui va choisir quel article
je vais proposer dans quelle mesure il
va être pertinent pour tel ou tel
individu et quel impact peut avoir
différentes informations sur différents
individus mais non seulement il est à la
tête de ça mais avant cela il a mis en
place ce qu'ils appellent le facebook
leur nord est dont le facebook leurs
moeurs est un outil chez facebook qui a
utilisé pour aller proposer aux
différents individus qui travaillent
chez facebook des outils très simples
sans avoir besoin de s'y connaître
excessivement en des gencives et
artificielle pour créer leurs propres
modèles
selon voilà les conseils du marketing
leur intuition vis-à-vis de leurs
projets au sein de facebook pour
proposer des petites outils comme ça de
d'intelligence artificielle évite les
mettre en place sur sur facebook
non seulement il va créer de ce secteur
là qui a interviewé il va créer de
l'intelligence artificielle et
d'algorithmes pour facebook mais en plus
il va proposer également à des outils
que facebook pourra l'utiliser pour
toujours infuser plus de machine
learning et plus d'intelligence
artificielle au sein de au sein du
réseau social
donc le processus de création chez
facebook c'est donc pour ce pour ce type
d'intérieur steevy ciel c'est ces petits
outils de machine learning
on va avoir un ingénieur qui va être mis
sur sur cette question là il va
travailler sur le facebook learner il va
aller tester sur un serveur avec un
nombre réduit d'individus sont
algorithmes d'apprentissage il va tirer
les conclusions de cet apprentissage
pour pouvoir maximiser justement
l'engagement dont on a parlé et donc la
visibilité de la de la publicité et une
fois qu'il aura testé il peut le déployé
six et validé ils eux ils déploient sur
sur le tout ce système mais le problème
est là quand le constat qu'on fait avec
ses petits outils d'intelligence
artificielle c'est qu'ils ont une
tendance extrêmement de la chose à
favoriser l'été exprès ministre les les
théories du complot les thèses
je sais pas sexiste raciste tout ce
qu'on veut et que il en retourne au tout
les choses qui nous font réagir tous les
choses qui créent des bas et qu' il va
délaisser les choses un peu plus nuancé
un peu plus consensuel parce que elle va
finalement déduire que ben ça vous
intéresse moins et que les choses un peu
plus nuancé et qui demande un peu plus
de réflexion
ça c'est une problématique qui s'est
montrée beaucoup notamment pendant la
crise qui s'est passé au myanmar
alors je sais pas si vous vous rappelez
c'est quelque chose qui a fait notamment
c'était en 2018
je crois que la musique de la crise
d'héroïne gaz ou 2010 9,4 et donc c'est
ce qui se passe c'est que au myanmar ya
une population musulmane qui s'appelle
les rires l'héroïne gaz et il va y avoir
de la part d'une partie de la population
et de la part d'une partie du
gouvernement
une campagne de
le discrimination de diffamation tout ce
qu'on veut sur sur cette population
musulmane comme quoi elle serait tous
les tours là si elle serait la cause de
tous les troubles dans le pays de tous
les problèmes d'un pays et ce qui va
être donnée du coup lieu à un génocide
il va se trouver que facebook va avoir
un rôle important dans cette dans la
diffusion de ces thèses extrémistes de
ses thèses discriminatoires sur les sur
l'héroïne gaz et que du coup on va avoir
une escalade d'un conflit religieux et
donc facebook va après reconnaître le
rôle quelques que la plateforme pu avoir
dans ce dans ce dans ce génocide dans
cette danse et horreur c'est pas ça et
d'ailleurs je vous lis ce qu'est ce que
ce serait si facebook également elle
reconnaît avoir joué un rôle dans le
fait de ne pas avoir empêché la
plateforme d'être utilisés pour
favoriser la division et inciter à la
violence
donc vraiment elle n'a pas été en mesure
donc là en plus c'est une défense de thé
bien que sa saveur dans l'euphémisme
mais l'idée c'est que c'est il fait doux
n'a pas réussi à empêcher la diffusion
voire à la facilité avec ses modèles
justement qui favorisent l'engagement à
diffuser des extrémistes il faut savoir
dans ce cadre là que 64% des
inscriptions à des groupes extrémistes
notamment sur dur et des suggestions
pour par l'intelligence artificielle
donc à de grandes chances que si je
rejoins à un groupe d'extrême droite un
groupe d'extrême gauche
un groupe comment dire identitaire un
groupe sexistes peu importe
64 % de ces inscriptions à ces groupes
là vont m'être dit par facebook
salut tu veux rejoindre ce groupe on dit
des horreurs sur des gens c'est possible
on peut en tout cas
en tout cas sur des groupes qui vont
faire réagir et qui vont questionner qui
sont pas forcément à nuancer avec des
news très impactante qui encore une fois
polarise le débat politique et du coup
vont avoir des effets nocifs
potentiellement sur la démocratie sur la
possibilité de discuter entre les gens
qui sont de différentes opinions
politiques que ce soit des gens de voir
le double droite extrême gauche extrême
droite peu importe peu importe lequel
idées en cédant ses différents individus
ils vont faire en sorte de les écarter
toujours plus le fait un climat toujours
plus important entre ces différentes
parties politiques quelles que soient
leurs idées et ils vont pas ce que va
faire facebook là dedans aussi c'est que
la perpétuer une puisque ce qu'une
notion intéressante qui s'appelle les
filter bubble c'est un peu la même c'est
un peu un concept qui est un peu
parallèle et pieter bruegel c1 c'est un
concept qui a été mis en place par eli
pariser est un cas un chercheur qu'un
journaliste qui sait la recherche en
2011 me semble et qui en fait le concept
de la filter google c'est de dire je
suis sur mon réseau social facebook par
exemple et je suis dans ma bulle
c'est à dire que j'aime par exemple le
skate les chiens et comment dire et
l'europe est de rome par exemple et bien
on va me proposer je suis de gauche
eh bien on va me proposer des choses qui
sont en relation avec ou parle de toutes
ces thématiques la ccc quelque chose du
coup qui va nous enfermer dans une
justement à la fois notre tendance
politique donc vous et du coup qui vont
nous amener à nous protéger une espèce
de bulle
dans ce qu'on appelle un biais de
confirmation c'est à dire je suis dans
l'ombre où je regarde que ce que j'aime
on me propose que ce que gm on me met en
sorte on me met en face juste dit les
politiques avec lesquelles je suis
d'accord et puis on avance et plus on
avance et finalement on arrive pas à
s'extraire ou à se poser des questions
sur le candidat reçoit là sur une autre
idée politique avec lesquels on n'aurait
pas forcément familière il ya une
possibilité selon facebook toujours ça
c'était un porte-parole de facebook
je sais plus et et chris cox en 2017 qui
sort une étude lassus qui travaille chez
facebook à ce moment-là qu'il était de
mon producteur fils aaron viles charges
et produits chez chez facebook et il dit
qu' il ya une possibilité de mettre en
place des mécanismes pour pouvoir
empêcher cessa empêcher ces bulles
empêcher ce clivage entre les
différentes identités politiques mais
que ce serait des mesures qui seraient
considérées comme anti groff donc ça
veut dire anti développement de facebook
anti engagement et sa s'oppose
évidemment au modèle économique de
facebook et donc puisque c'est nocif
pour le développement de la plate forme
évidemment cdd été encore une fois pas
du tout nos théories du complot c'est
une logique commerciale ou telle qu'elle
est conçue
ça va au blond ça va amener les
commentaires les dirigeants de facebook
pulls et les ingénieurs de facebook a
pas mettre en place ce genre de
commentaires de deux mécanismes pouvoir
se défendre défectueuse et devait de ce
genre de et de ce type de mécanisme donc
là on voit c'est ce qui se passe
naturellement dans le sur le réseau
social
c'est à dire que plus on va s'approcher
de la policie line c'est à dire la règle
au delà de laquelle on a dépassé les
cadres de la légalité selon facebook
donc ça peut être un discours
ouvertement raciste ouvertement
négationniste ouvertement sexy
ouvertement diffamatoire pour certaines
personnes et bien plus on va s'approcher
de cette ligne la plus on va dire des
choses qui frôle avec l'illégalité avec
le voilà est bien plus on va avoir de
l'engagement plus on va avoir des gens
qui s'intéressent à ce à ce contenu là
et à ce moment là
mark zuckerberg comme le dirigeant de
fait vous pouvez arriver il va dire non
non
notre but c'est l'inversé plus on
s'approche de 7,2 cette ligne de ces
lignes un petit peu borderline avec la
légalité
plus on va faire en sorte de diminuer
l'engagement alors non seulement c'est
assez c'est assez marrant parce que
c'est assez stéréotypé qui quand même
comme comme comme façon de voir le monde
c'est assez binaire et puis on se doute
bien que typiquement ce genre de
fonctionnement seraient extrêmement
nocif pour la plate forme voire pourrait
voir la plateforme être balayés par les
individus au fur et à mesure que
puisqu'on le rapprochant rahman a plus
que du contenu qui est qui et qui ne
suscite pas d'intérêt chez eux donc pour
eux c'est absolument absolument des
questions de médecins en place une autre
thématique est venu un petit peu
influencé la façon dont dans le
l'intelligence artificielle sous peu
importe c'est un hashtag qui a été mis
en place par notamment john et par ses
supporters pendant la campagne je vois
que ta dépendance à sa première campagne
et c'était stop de bs c'est à dire qu'il
y avait un reproche de la part des
républicains à ce moment là dans cette
campagne là de dire eh bien vous voyez
facebook qui est dans la silicon valley
donc il ya plutôt une affinité avec avec
des idées un petit peu de
d'utopie un petit peu démocratique voilà
il se prétend le code qui se présente
comme tel avec des gens plutôt à gauche
tout ça et donc du coup bas ces
entreprises qui le jugent bien pensante
bah forcément elles elles vont en plus
avoir tendance à favoriser les
démocrates et des vues un petit peu plus
un peu plus égalitaire que nous
républicain avec nos vision libertaire
et conservatrice et tout cela et donc du
coup il va y avoir un outil qui va être
mis en place alors je ne sais pas si je
gagne la manche génial qui va être mis
en place c'est le ferney ce flou c'est à
dire c'est une un mécanisme de la barre
de facebook qui va dire bon ok on va non
plus essayer de se baser sur qu'est-ce
qu'il est faux que ce qui est vrai mais
plutôt qu'est ce qui permet une équité
or on a vu et ça c'est pas un jugement
de valeur c'est là je vous renverrai
ressources que je mettrai en commentaire
après le après le soleil là c'est une
capacité pour les républicains à d a
disposé de et à diffuser plus de fait qu
news que les démocrates
ça c'est pas les gens comme toi c'est
pas une opinion c'est vraiment ça a été
ça a été démontré à maintes reprises par
plusieurs études et donc du coup
facebook s'est dit ok nous on a
extrêmement peur que si les républicains
arrive au pouvoir
on est françois face à des gens qui ont
envie de nous régulée par la voie
législative de verrouiller un petit peu
comment fonctionne facebook n'est plus
justement la possibilité nous en tant
qu'entreprise privée de se réguler nous
mêmes donc on va mettre en place un
outil qui n'empêche pas tant les fausses
informations ou clivages que avoir une
moitié de pour d'être très schématique
une moitié de postes en faveur des
républicains et une moitié de postes en
faveur des démocrates souhaiteraient
gematik mais en gros ont brossé 7 cette
problématique là et ça ça encore une
fois pas du tout pour objet de rendre
l'intelligence artificielle plus
intelligente plus saine pour le débat
démocratique mais simplement de dire aux
législateurs nom est inquiète parce qu
on est équitable laisse nous tranquilles
les slows gérer notre entreprise comme
on le souhaite
ce que dit joaquin qui ne sert donc je
rappelle qu'il directement
l'intelligence artificielle j'ai vu
facebook etc et l interviewer principal
de ce deux sets de 7 cet article il dit
que l'intelligence artificielle déjà et
pas si brillante que ça que une et comme
on l'a vu une équité politique n'est pas
forcément une équité d'informations et
surtout que la faille de l'intelligence
artificielle est avant tout une faille
de l'humain c'est à dire que en gros on
ralentit en voiture quand on voit un
accident on ralentit en voiture quand on
voit une bagarre des gens ceux des gens
ce type a commencé sa mère mais il ya
une propension effectivement au drame
aux chocs à l'impact ans et que du coup
l intelligence artificielle ne fait que
répondre à ce besoin et donc du coup
c'est naturel en tout cas pour nous
d'être attiré par cette part ces choses
radical et donc du coup c'est naturel
pour nous aussi de les partager de les
diffuser et de partager soit notre
indignation soit notre notre colère soit
à peu importe
plutôt qu'un propos nuancés avec
quelqu'un qui dit un peu un peu un peu
de un peu gauche un peu droite et qu'il
essaie de faire quelque chose d'un petit
peu un peu nuancé dans ce débat là il se
demande du coup
donc c'est la fin du traitement de cet
article là à la fin le l'auteur de
l'article dit justement est ce que il
est possible d'avoir du coup une réponse
technologique assez bien et est ce que
cela serait souhaitable que y est
justement une réponse de largeur
officielle de la part de facebook et
surtout la dernière question qu'elle
pose c'est est ce qu'il serait possible
pour facebook maintenant que
l'intelligence artificielle est devenue
si grosse si importante
et si avec des capitaux
si déterminant est ce que l'intelligence
officielle est aujourd'hui capable
d'aller contre cette loi de l'engagement
absolu et ce besoin absolu de créer de
créer de l'awb l'engagement est là une
réponse assez intéressante et assez est
assez perturbante aussi de
l'intelligence 2-2 de jacques outin 0 le
directeur de la chaire d'intelligence
artificielle il dit j'en sais rien donc
c'est à dire qu'on a le directeur de
l'intelligence artificielle d'une des
plus grosses boîtes qui diffuse le plus
d'informations au monde au plus grand
nombre de personnes possible qui dit je
sais pas vraiment si on est en mesure de
faire que l'intelligence artificielle se
raisonne et qu'elle puisse assainir
justement dévale public en tout cas le
rendre un peu plus un peu plus
transparent et justement équilibré pour
pal justement quand on se tient dans les
pattes et que l'on soit de gauche de
droite ou qu'on soit de telles opinions
sur tel ou tel sujet on puisse ne pas
forcément s'écharper sur ces questions
donc d'un point donc je trouve que c'est
assez à la fois un constat intéressant
pour comprendre la façon dont
l'intelligence artificielle est rigide
et aussi c'est assez flippant sûr
finalement ce que peu ce que peut
engendrer par des artificiers d'un point
de vue d'un point de vue politique voilà
voilà donc s'asseyent pour le premier
article
alors je vais voir si plus tout seul à
parler ou si éventuellement il ya des
gens qui sont là et qui et qui
éventuellement réagissent à saccager pas
il ya une absence complète de réaction
donc je vais continuer c'est pas moi je
continue à parler tout seul mais bien au
non alors que je dirais si quelqu'un une
question donc là dessus ou pas je prends
un peu de ce que l'on peut plus par an
en tout cas si vous avez des questions
sur ce premier article
hésitez pas à me les partager et puis
dans une minute s'il n'a pas forcément
une question j'enchaînerai sûr
j'enchaînerai sur le l'article suivant
qu'ils voient sur la retraite reçu un
petit coup je balance mais qui jeta un
professionnel de la radio un ferme
wallace il n'y a pas de question et ce
comment vous entendez bien est-ce que
tout va bien est ce que c'est trop long
est-ce que ça fait quand même temps
l'envié ça fait un bout de verre sur un
article
il en reste deux j'aime beaucoup trop
long un petit peu trop
un petit peu trop bas par notre ami mais
après ce sera intéressant que ce soit si
vous voyez cette vidéo en direct ou que
ou si vous la voyez en différé qu'on
puisse avoir
du coup une que je puisse avoir un
retour sur le fait est ce que c est ce
qu il faut que je passe plus de temps
est-ce que faut que tu as moins de temps
est ce que finalement pour faire plus
d'articles moins d'articles voilà
n'hésitez pas à me dire et puis un peu
qu'on puisse éventuellement en parler à
arras je me mets trop parfait donc 60
elle est celle du coup google jouable il
n'y a pas d'élection donc c'est parce
que les gens sont tellement c'est
tellement clair que beaucoup d'actions
avant 3 heures ça donc le deuxième
article qu'on va traiter
c'est un article d'un gars y était écrit
par le rem good et qui a été publiée
dans wired en 2020 et qui s'appelle
accordant smiling des intenational
feuillette donc j'ai amené mon mariage
et l'internet ne l'oubliera jamais donc
ça va parler du coût de mémoire et
numérique alors mais plutôt mauvaise de
mauvaises méthodologie je vais vous
expliquer quel est le cadre général de 2
article glory good elle est en couple
depuis un certain temps et le prévoit
son mariage ce qui va se passer c'est
que en 2019
donc avant la pandémie c'est un couple
qui va comme certains couples vont se
leva se flétrir pour finalement ne plus
avoir vraiment d'intérêt l'un pour
l'autre et donc du coup qui va choisir
de se séparer
donc il va y avoir une préparation du
mariage un petit peu en amont mais
finalement est déçu de pas se marier et
2 et 2 et 2 et de choisir chacun leur
leur chemin par rapport par rapport à ça
là on va voir ça les 1/4 un petit peu
différent d'aujourd'hui avec pas mal de
gens qui malheureusement dukes doivent
annuler le la date de leur mariage en
espérant quand même que tout cela pour
pouvoir reprendre plus sereinement
donc ça va parler de quoi du coup ça va
parler de mémoire avec numérique c'est à
dire comment internet est capable de se
souvenir bahreïn événements et comment
il est capable aussi de ne pas l'oublier
donc intelligence difficiel et droit à
l'oubli l'inertie des réseaux sociaux
par rapport à ça donc de la capacité de
l'intelligence artificielle à comprendre
ces questions là et à nous envoyer des
stéréotypes pour pouvoir un petit peu
mieux mieux comprendre les différentes
thématiques qui sont qui sont en jeu et
intelligence artificielle et rentabilité
aussi c'est à dire en quoi justement
cette notion de mémoire cette notion de
nostalgie est ce qu'elle peut nous
provoquer
dans quelle mesure encore une fois il en
va voir c'est un petit peu la même
problématique qu'avant c'est à dire en
quoi ce qui ne peut nous faire du bien
peut être en opposition avec ce qui peut
créer du profit de l'engagement pour les
réseaux sociaux et pour les publicités
qu'elle qu'elle peut qu'elle peut
diffuser donc selon elle va se plaindre
cette lorraine good c'est que elle va
annuler son mariage et que cependant les
réseaux sociaux vont pas vraiment capté
que ce mariage est
mulet et donc ils vont parler de lui
proposer encore et encore des robes de
mariée de la décoration et sur piste et
reste donc à il comptait reste pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas assez un réseau
social depuis on nous propose
différentes différentes différentes
photos d inspiration pour pour des tv de
mort en 2d la façon dont on s'habille
20,9 à la mode façon de consommer
principalement il faut pas lui amener
des vivres par était lui a amené des
photos de mariage parfaite alors que l
justement son mariage un petit peu tombé
à l'eau et elle va particulièrement mal
de vivre et donc du coup la physique
tard ainsi que l'apparition de seins en
disant notamment en ce qu'ils sont et
non sur la question de la nostalgie
parce que depuis un certain temps on va
voir apparaître sur les réseaux sociaux
alors vous avez peut-être vu sur sur vos
propres sociaux si vous les utilisez sur
facebook par exemple on a la paix
l'apparition de hunt 10 days c'est à
dire on a une photo qui date de 2010 9
2017 2010 qu'on a pris sur facebook et
bah ce jour là sur facebook vous avez
publiée telle ou telle photo et ils ont
remarqué chez facebook notamment chez
instagram ils le font aussi
chez sur les apple photo ils le font
également que ça faisait beaucoup réagir
les gens et donc ça va amener des
commentaires du style à l'état but à
quoi ressemblait il ya dix ans et cette
nostalgie elle fait réagir elle va créer
une émotion chez le ch et l'utilisateur
et donc du coup encore une fois il va
créer ce qu'on a défini précédemment
c'est à dire de l'engagement à la base
on a du mal à définir un petit peu à
quel moment c'est cet attrait pour la
nostalgie s'est mis en place sur les
lieux sociaux
mais en 2010 je crois que c'est en 2001
en 2011 par l'eau on va avoir la
réaction d'une application qui s'appelle
times up et donc times up c'est une
application qui a fait grand bruit aux
états unis comptent y avait deux
millions d'utilisateurs je pense qu'à
beaucoup moins d'utilisateurs
aujourd'hui il y avait 12 millions
d'utilisateurs et l'idée c'était
2 justement de stocker les photos sur
cette application là et que jour après
jour l'application pouvait proposer des
photos qui datait de temps de tant
d'années de tant de moi et nous remettre
du coude et des souvenirs de moments
potentiellement un cam potentiellement
moins agréable c'est ce qu'on va voir
après et ensuite facebook donc cette
application va cartonner et on va avoir
ensuite justement facebook instagram ou
apple ouvre même microsoft ou s'il a
fait des choix dernièrement et qui va
utiliser cette technique de la nostalgie
pour pouvoir créer de l'engagement créé
ducret et deux des commentaires et ainsi
de suite
d'ailleurs il est à noter qu'aujourd'hui
les créateurs de taille pop travail
respectivement chez sap chat et
instagram
ce qui évidemment pas demain et ce qui
montre qu'il ya un vrai traite ses
plates formes là pour la nostalgie et
pour ce qu'elle jamais enchaîné
d'ailleurs installé rigolo parce que on
a chez un stade de base la nostalgique
et même dans l'essence même de cette de
cette notion de nostalgie c'est à dire
que instagram c'est des filtres qui font
paraître la photo comme une photo
argentique une technologie qu'on
n'utilise quasiment plus donc quand on
publie la photo d'instagram elle est de
par son esthétique elle est quasiment
déjà ancré dans le passé
donc c'est une technique qui écrivent
beaucoup employé je mettrai en lien
encore une fois cette notion là dedans
le dans la description du lab une fois
qu'il sera sorti à une
une chercheuse extrêmement intéressant
que cb qatarienne niemeyer qui a
travaillé justement sur l'exploitation
sémiologique de la delà de la nostalgie
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir créer de
l'engagement écrit de l'émotion chez eux
chez les auditeurs spectateurs ou ou
utilisateurs des réseaux sociaux les
mémoires digital ça permet effectivement
d'engendrer des moments agréables mais
cependant ça va poser deux questions
c'est-à-dire une question éthique et une
question émotionnel la première une
question éthique parce qu'on va se
demander est ce que il est bien
morales pour une application de utile
d'utiliser nos souvenirs d'utiliser
notre vie précédente et l'image qu'on
s'en fait pour la monétiser pour se
faire de l'argent puisque encore une
fois c'est fait de la visibilité donc et
donc de l'engagement
est-ce que c'est intéressant
effectivement d'avoir cette ses
souvenirs là qui reviennent en boucle
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
émotionnel puisque
beaucoup de chercheurs viennent un peu
fustigé ce principe là alors beaucoup de
chercheurs pas assez il semble mais on a
notamment calé corne qui est une
chercheuse justement sur ces thématiques
là qui dit que oublié c'était c'était le
standard s'était ce qui se passait par
défaut mais le fait d'oublier ça permet
aussi d'éviter nos mémoires et donc
quand il dit est dit et nos mémoires
c'est à dire c'est avoir la capacité
éventuellement de mettre certaines
mémoires de côté pour pouvoir être
capable d'avoir un peu plus de place
pour pouvoir en développant d'en
développer de nombreux souvenirs mais ça
peut vouloir dire aussi d'éditer pour
pouvoir effacer certains éléments mais y
aurait certaines certaines certains
éléments un peu plus un peu plus
compliqué et donc du coup éventuellement
de pouvoir négocier avec certains trauma
et ce qu'elle dit et cette chercheuse là
c'est que en allant tout le temps sur le
terrain de la nostalgie en mettant en
boucle ses vieux souvenirs et ses vieux
et ses vieux et ses vieilles thématique
on va en permanence créer une boucle
infinie dans lesquels on va être aux
plongées et on va et de replonger dans
le passé en permanence et donc
potentiellement on va être plongée
également comme trop mal si si c'est le
moment s'apparente s'apparente à une un
moment désagréable ou un moment
compliqué pour nous
juste fini en citant le incitant la
commandite jeremy thilleman qui
justement revient là dessus sur le fait
que l'intelligence artificielle est pas
capable d'aller identifié david
identifier ces choses là
c'est une chose de dire je veux de
nouvelles chaussures et d'avoir une
application qui nous suivent ensuite sur
internet pour me l'a proposé mais
certains indicateurs comme le mariage
par exemple représente une autoroute une
opportunité spécifique pour les
professionnels du marketing est
évidemment plus précieuses informations
plus intrusive et la publicité
donc on va avoir une difficulté de se
sortir de ces éléments là notamment des
éléments très chargé comme une essence
comme un mariage et le chef de produit
chez pinta reste va appeler ça des
fausses couches
donc on va avoir des gens qui font
partie de la minorité
c'est à dire que généralement dans la
majorité quand on commence à organiser
un mariage on est en place on va voir
que c'est c'est un peu plus compliqué
avec avec malheureusement élus locaux
vides d'avoir forcément une automatique
de vol organisé puis il se vide ce
réalisme j'espère que tout le monde
pourra bien faire quand même
mais on va avoir aussi des femmes qui
tombent enceintes et malheureusement qui
font des fausses couches
on va avoir des vacances qui devait être
prévu et puis finalement qui tombe à
l'eau mais ça le réseau social
l'intelligence artificielle justement
des réseaux sociaux
elle va avoir du mal à le capter pour
deux raisons la première c'est parce que
il ya bien que la majorité c'est à dire
que là j'ai cherché des données de la
flèche et c est là j'ai dit que les
fausses couches là je parle de femmes
enceintes qui font des fausses couches
on est entre 10 et 15%
donc c'est une donnée qui est
relativement négligeable pour les gens
qui sont dans le marketing c'est à dire
que je sais que si on est de 10 à 15%
que si je lance par exemple si la
personne s'exprime sur le fait qu'elle
va être enceinte vous que l'intelligence
de fiel comprend qu'elle est enceinte
la personne se dit que pendant neuf mois
et puis potentiellement pendant ensuite
un an deux ans trois ans en fonction
d'eux
l'âge de l'enfant on va pouvoir aller
lui proposer différents produits et que
du coup ben tant pis pour les gens qui
font une fausse couche
certaines formes de cruauté là dedans
les six en tout cas de en tout cas de
mépris pour les sentiments les questions
émotionnel lui-même bas elle est là la
femme qui a fait une fausse couche bien
j'ai quand même à lui proposer un
berceau j'ai quand même nous proposait
d'aider des habits d'enfants j'ai quand
même lui proposer cela et cela en dépit
du coût de la charge émotionnelle que ça
peut avoir pour pour l'individu qui est
concerné donc voilà une grosse
problématique là dessus est vrai que le
fait que chez bing terrestre ils
appellent ça une fausse couche
c'est problématique parce que ça veut
dire qu'ils se rendent compte de la
portée émotionnelle que peut avoir
justement ces arrêts ces interruptions
d'événements que ce soit un mariage une
naissance là je cite ces deux là parce
que c'est les plus on va dire que c'est
les plus symboliques essais les plus
importants d'une vie en tout cas pour
beaucoup de gens et donc puisque ça
représente une donnée négligeable et que
ça représente pourtant une opportunité
incroyable pour les marques et pour les
pour les responsables marketing d'aller
fournir de l'information et donc du coup
de s'accaparer une certaine partie du
pouvoir d'achat de ces gens là et là on
va avoir c'est ce flux incessant
d'informations qui vont abonder qui vont
abonder dans ce sens là et donc du coup
lauren booth d'affaires le gars de l'est
l'auteur de l'article va faire
l'expérience de cela et donc elle va
avoir une proposition
deux robes de mariée de déco de mariage
en permanence
elle va essayer d'arrêter de comment
dire de d'aller couper un petit peu avec
les sites sur lesquels elle allait
notamment sur sur sociaux pour pouvoir
voir mais il se trouve que plusieurs
mois après même après avoir essayé de
montrer un peu arrêté de suivre les
comptes qu'ils étaient il ya des
mariages tout ça on nous proposait
toujours des choses qui étaient en
mesure en lien avec le mariage et il
faut savoir que c'est notamment apple
facebook et google il me semble qu'ils
ont commencé à essayer de tâtonner sur
ce terrain là et qui ont commencé à se
dire ah bon les photos notamment qui ont
lien avec une ambulance avec un hôpital
on va essayer de les écarter et de pas
les faire remonter chez les gens ou de
ne pas les faire pour part
éventuellement aller chercher un
souvenir un petit peu un peu douloureux
mais ça pose question nécessairement c
est ce qu est ce que ça existe un moment
hospitalier heureux peut-être il ya par
exemple un enfant inespéré qui
finalement arrive c'est un événement
extrêmement heureux une sortie de
maladie c'est un événement extrêmement
heureux en ambulance ça peut être pareil
quelqu'un qui tombe enceinte et qui
finalement en cause dans l'ambulance et
ça se passe bien donc l'intérieur syfy
ciel évidemment il aujourd'hui pas
capable encore de et elle le sera
peut-être jamais d'identifier ces
nuances là et donc du coup d'avoir
toujours une proposition erronée
vis-à-vis de ça et l'intelligence
artificielle du coup n'est toujours pas
capable d'aller d'aller capter ces
nuances et de pouvoir en faire une
conclusion qui est plus saine
encore une fois pour l'émotion humaine
telle qu'elle a ressenti par les gens
justement qui liront des imprévus dans
la vie parce que on en a chacun et qui
du coup souffre de cette de sept de ces
événements douloureux de ses traumas
qu'on n'arrête pas de leur remettre en
tête et qui justement créer des e books
incessantes de de deuil ou deux par
rapport à par rapport à quelqu'un de de
deuil d'une relation de deuil d'un d'un
d'une dune d'un enfant qui allait naître
de tout ces éléments là sont
malheureusement que peu floués par les
incapacités à la fois les incapacités
l'intelligence artificielle et puis
l'opposition qu'il peut y avoir entre
eux les intérêts économiques de la plate
forme d'aller proposer des produits et
les publicités très ciblées pour les
gens qui sont enceintes à la majorité
des gens pour ça va bien se passer
et puis données liées et ceux pour qui
les avoir plus de difficultés à passer
d'un événement un autre elle fait une
j'étais assez surpris par la conclusion
que faisait l'auteur loterie ce nom de
l'auteur j'ai un doute bref c'était bull
riding hood elle qui va dire qu'on en
fait
l'intelligence artificielle est une
problématique les réseaux sociaux vont
avoir une monétise sa monétise le nôtre
nos événements ne monétise nous souvenir
par le fait de créer de l'engagement par
rapport aux mémoires qu'on peut avoir et
tout ça mais que finalement c'est mieux
de ressentir quelque chose plutôt de
conomor ressentir ça c'était une
citation d'un écrivain qui s'appelle
andré aciman mais c'est très
questionnable
et du coup on peut se poser la question
de duke on peut avoir plusieurs
positionnement par rapport à ça soit on
s'extrait complètement les réseaux
sociaux en disant qu'on veut pas subir
cette ce diktat de la nostalgie qui est
imposé par les réseaux sociaux soit on
avait besoin de prendre un peu de recul
et de et de da de pouvoir avoir un
raisonnement critique mais habité
comportement de l'algorithme soit on
fait avec en ligne ormes et puis on
estime qu' on estime qu'on va avoir que
peu importe ce qui va se passer on va de
toute façon avoir une une un avis assez
assez assez
aujourd'hui ces cent par rapport à par
rapport à tout ça à mon avis assez
pondéré et se dire que finalement c'est
pas si grave que ça vous laisse juger
évidemment moi je ne prononce pas de
temps sur la question que ça mais
d'idées voilà c'est de pouvoir au moins
avoir connaissance de cette notion-là de
comment ça fonctionne pour pouvoir y
apposer du coup quelque chose de un avis
un peu plus un peu plus avisés
sur cette problématique de
la moindre possibilité d'oublier le fait
que les réseaux sociaux se nourrissent
de cette nostalgie là et que il peut
remettre en question certains processus
naturels tels que l'oubli pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir proposer toujours plus de
d'éléments pour pouvoir créer deux
langues activement les banques créent la
de la publicité
voilà voilà pour le deuxième article il
est 10h49 j'ai encore parlé bien trop
alors le point d'un titre est vraiment
plus long là le dernier article va être
il va être un peu plus un peu plus a
remué le court je valais tik tok et qui
moi non j'ai 28 ans et j'avoue que tik
tok moi c'est une platine que j'ai alors
dont j'ai entendu parler
et c'était parti que là qui m'a donné
envie un peu plus de l'intérêt ça la
plateforme je bois encore ce que c'est
hyper compétent 2.686 vous avez encore
des des questions ou que sais-je
c'est avec eux c'est avec grand plaisir
il ya quand même dix mille personnes qui
regardent en ce moment voilà il faut pas
regarder non de spectateurs mais vous
êtes un peu près des mines et énergies
franck est pas une question n'est encore
une fois c'est pas du tout parce qu'il
ya là vous comprendre parce que j'ai
extrêmement cas voilà voilà pour cette
vanne donc on va passer au troisième
article apprend à faire une petite
conclusion est troisième et dernier
article du couple et puis si s'il n'y a
pas de 6 a pas de questions derrière moi
écouter on finira là dessus l'idée c'est
que c'est vrai que si peu à des
questions ça peut être cool qui a des
questions à la fin de ce troisième
article pour revisionner un petit peu
les thématiques pour posez peut-être
éventuellement des questions qu'on pas
forcément à voir avec ces articles là
directement mais plutôt qu'on va voir
avec eux qu'on va voir avec là qu'on va
voir avec le
l'intelligence artificielle dans les
réseaux sociaux les expériences
éventuellement vous avez pu avoir par
rapport à ces éléments là c'est toujours
intéressant
au pire ce que je ferai c'est peut-être
une petite pause après ce troisième
article de deux minutes où je sers
maîtres de la musique
si je fais assez fort techniquement que
certains et une fois que une fois que ce
sera fait je reviendrai puis s'il ya des
questions et on va tranquillement
voilà c'est vraiment un jour besoin
ok donc un jeu disait tipp taxe est une
application
jusque là rien de bien nouveau thème
demographia ces jeunes j'ai pas les
chiffres exacts et j'ai corrigé
en fait j'ai fait plusieurs chiffres
mais qui un peu se contredisaient donc
j'ai préféré pas avancé de chiffres mais
tous les tous les les
les articles tous depuis lors ceux ci
jala tendez à dire que effectivement
c'est une démographie plutôt jeune et
que l'âge moyen pouvait fluctué entre 16
et 19 ans parce que j'ai ce que j'ai
repéré
donc c'est pas un réseau social qui est
plutôt utilisé par par des jeunes moi
j'ai 28 ans donc je ne l'avais pas
forcément utiliser justement parce que
tu avais aussi c'est peu ce préjugé que
c'était pas principalement utilisés par
des parts d'audience et que le coup je
pouvais je voyais pas trop ce que je
pouvais m'en retirer
je les télécharger il ya cela suite à la
lecture de cet article est téléchargé il
ya de cela quelques semaines
et j'avoue d'avoir un peu fait les mêmes
conclusions que cette hauteur là sur sur
cette thématique là et je suis assez
reconnus dans la façon dont j'ai pu
réagir sur cette cette application l'a
donc pour ceux qui connaissent pas
l'application elle est assez facile à
expliquer de façon assez grossière vous
avez votre application vous la lancez
vous propose quelques thématiques que
vous avez bien humour je sais pas
musique voiture skateboard surf chiens
chats niveau bref tout ça et puis de là
vous lancer et vous allez avoir des
vidéos qui vont s'enchaîner avec une
fonctionnalité avec une 2 interactions
principal qui sera le 26 villes et les
principales des interactions vous allez
faire avec cette avec 7,7
cette plateforme soit vous allez mettre
votre pouce vers le haut et ça va
revenir à la vidéo précédente soit vous
allez glisser vers le bas et ça va aller
à la vidéo d'après ces vidéos qui sont
généralement rythmée par de la musique
ccc est prévu dans le fonctionnement de
tik tok et puis c'est quelque chose qui
va revenir en permanence sur des
montages de 60 secondes et simplement
cette action là c'est à dire passer
tellement regardé une vidéo passer une
autre vidéo éventuellement lalique et ça
c'est possible si la ligue et mais
vraiment la chose dont se nourrit le
tictoc principalement c'est le fait
effectivement d'avoir cette recette se
soumet ce scroll en bas ou en gros et
qui va déterminer l'intérêt que
l'utilisateur va avoir de tel ou tel
vide et donc de quoi ça va parler du
coup maintenant qu'on a un petit peu
c'est rare mais quelle est l application
est donc c'est
comment le l'application s'y prend pour
faire de la captation de la tension
comment elle personnalise les flux
d'intérêt et en quoi elle est
particulièrement pertinente pour le
faire et en quoi par rapport aux autres
sociaux on savait vraiment ce qui va
différencier des autres sociaux et c'est
pour ça que j'ai choisi d'en parler
parce que on va voir qui est une
approche qui est vraiment différente de
ce qu'on peut trouver sur twitter
facebook ou instagram est donc en quoi
ça entraîne une forme de passivité et
des nouvelles formes du coût de
consommation médiatique donc ce que
l'auteur dit dans un premier temps c'est
que on va voir
fondamentalement on va voir mais on
revient au point qu'on en a
fondamentalement une une différence avec
avec les autres sociaux c'est que on a
une captation de la tension qui est
absolument incroyable parce que on va
passer d'une vidéo à l'autre extrêmement
rapidement et à partir de ça le field de
tik tok va essayer de comprendre quelles
sont nos intérêts quelles sont les
choses qui peuvent attirer notre
attention et va essayer de se nourrir de
ça pour nous proposer
coup après coup les meilleurs les
meilleurs contenus on va avoir du coût
des choses qui des différents si
justement vers la part d'autres sociale
les similarités les contrastes déjà la
plupart des réseaux sociaux vont se
baser sur le principe de similarité
c'est à dire que je vais avoir
potentiellement sur youtube je vais
regarder des vidéos de dauphin eh bien
il ya de grandes chances qu'on nous
propose des vidéos d'animaux sur le côté
ou des vidéos de dauphin tik tok celle
inverse tik tok me va me proposer une
photo une vidéo de skate faut que
j'arrête de parler de ce qu est une
vidéo de skate et la vidéo précédente
la vidéo suivante c'est quelqu'un qui se
brossent les cheveux après ça va être
quelqu'un qui raconte une vanne
après ça va être quelqu'un qui tombe
dans un dans un puits après ça avait été
le cas qui explique comment faire du
savon naturel ou peu importe les vidéos
quand elles se suivent n'ont absolument
aucune cohérence entre elles
c est ce qui va être très interpellant
dans ces vidéos là mais malgré le fait
que les vidéos n'ont pas vraiment de
rapport entre elles puisque on va
affiner on va personnaliser de par nos
gestes
l'algorithme va comprendre ce qui nous
attire ou pas ben finalement ça va quand
même créer quelque chose de cohérent
dans lequel on va se reconnaître qu'il
va être un peu hypnotique dans lequel on
va passer de plus en plus de plus en
plus de temps on peut faire le parallèle
avec spotify aussi si j'écoute je sais
pas même si solar par exemple au passage
il ya peu de chance qu'on me propose du
rock and roll un peu agressif derrière
on va plutôt proposé soit un autre titre
d'un petit soir après l écoute soit dû
aux coûts beaucoup de cheminots soit un
autre titre en de rap français peu
importe mais on va pas arriver sur un
genre complètement différent alors quoi
encore une fois je peux regarder une
vidéo de de quelqu'un qui joue très bien
du piano / tik tok et puis enchaîner
derrière ce quelqu'un qui quitteront
seul en art dans un bois alors que je ne
connais pas je connais pas cette
personne me suis jamais intéressé à ça
mais n'empêche que j'ai regardé parce
que voilà ça m'intéresse
les gens qui consomment des trucs dans
les bois c'est bizarre cette phrase est
une ode différenciation donc le pas qui
mais quoi c'est la différenciation
notamment qu'on peut trouver avec avec
twitter j'écoute la voix des gens qui me
parlent et twitter c'est ça c'est que je
vais avant tout me concentrer sur la
provenance de deux des gens sur qui est
sûre sur twitter avant même de lire le
message généralement je vais
m'intéresser à kim parle
est ce que c'est un conte qui est
vérifiée ou pas bon de vérifier sa vue
de la rencontre plutôt d'une personne
avec un petit peu de l'audience qui est
reconnue et qui éveille des twitter
comme étant la bonne personne je vais
regarder combien à la personne je vais
pas évidemment prendre la même la même
chose d'une blague sexiste d'un élu
rassemblement national par exemple et
d'un d'un humoriste de de qui je sais
très bien n'a absolument rien de sexiste
et qui justement veut faire ça aux deux
secondes audrey l'importance vraiment
c'est la provenance de qui parle sur tik
tok c'est très différent au contraire
c'est le contenu on n'a pas alors il ya
certaines stars de stocks et des gens
qui se mettent en avant de gaza mais
quand je scroll dans mon film comme ça
avec thual it et je m'intéresse pas de
temps à chili produit la vidéo parce que
je ne connais pas nécessairement et puis
parce que je me suis pas abonnés à ce
contenu mais plutôt qu'est ce que me
propose la vidéo et c'est ça qui va être
très importante il toque c'est qu'on va
un petit peu d personnifié aussi pour
reposer justement du contenu du contenu
du contenu en zapping permanent
on va avoir aussi donc justement ses
capacités pour l'algorithme d'aller
proposer toujours plus d'individus tour
plus de 2
deux contenus différents qui viennent un
petit peu étoffé mon fils et qui va
éventuellement puisqu'il propose des
choses très différentes auxquelles je
peux adhérer ou non il va très vite
pouvoir constituer une espèce de
myriades de d'univers qui m'est propre
deux vidéos que j'ai mes deux vidéos qui
attend leurs intérêts et du coup créer
un espèce de microcosme dans lequel je
me sens bien qu'ils me proposent des
choses que j'aime et qui me propose des
choses qui peuvent susciter mon intérêt
et mimiques nautiz est comme ça pendant
pendant plusieurs minutes ou plusieurs
plusieurs heures enfin moi plus en ce
sens n'avait pas encore arrivé mais
pourquoi pas et donc il va être très
pertinent justement pour me rendre
captif de cela et en plus m'identifier
très précisément également d'invendus
d'un point de vue publicitaire
enfin j'ai appelé ça l'effet casino mais
je sais pas si ça s'appelle l'effet
casino massa m'a évoqué ça parce que
vous savez il ya on dit qu'à las vegas
je suis jamais mais on dit dans les
films que la particularité de las vegas
et qu' il n'y a pas de fenêtre on voit
pas s'il fait jour si elle lui est tombé
6 ou autre chose et il n'ya pas
d'horloge
ce qui fait que la personne qui est dans
le casino ne sait pas vraiment combien
de temps depuis combien de temps elle
est en train de jouer et éventuellement
depuis combien de temps il est en train
de dépenser son argent
tik tok fait la même chose c'est à dire
que on n'a pas de marqueur de temps
particulier on sait pas quand été posté
la vidéo très c'est pas évident on a pas
de notion de combien de temps dure la
vidéo ce qui fait qu'on peut très
rapidement passé une heure sur la vidéo
en question sur les surveille le fils en
question sans pour autant s'être aperçu
du temps qui passait et en plus le fait
que les vidéos ne soit pas de date et on
va avoir en permanence un sentiment que
ce qui se déroule devant nos yeux c'est
une forme de présents et donc là encore
ça va un côté extrêmement extrêmement
impactant donc l'auteur relate l'auteur
parle vraiment d'un l'auteur parle
vraiment d'un feed dans lequel
environ avec un environnement immersif
dans lequel l'utilisateur va se plonger
va rester immergé dans un univers qui va
lui que le semble et plaisant cohérent
et dans lequel il va cela il va se
complaire pendant plusieurs temps à
consommer de l'image encore et encore
donc là c'est vraiment in our là je suis
pas trompé qui dit qu'ils étaient en
fait l'ancienne rédactrice en chef de
éditrice en chef avec les thrashers 3-2
de vanity fair mais les jeunes
américains qui dit que du coup son
journal le succès d'édition journal
c'est que c'était un mix parfait entre
des news importantes des portraits
étoffé de célébrités des photos glamour
et des critiques pertinentes sur
notamment la culture et tik tok
il est capable mieux que n'importe
quelle intelligence artificielle les
autres réseaux sociaux est encore plus
pertinemment que n'importe quel éditeur
humain de proposer un contenu un mix
parfait mais en plus dosée pour chaque
individu c'est calme depuis un an dans
un bar et qu'on commande est notre
cocktail ne pas avoir à mon goût par
rapport à n'importe quel à n'importe
quel trait de personnalité et que ça
allait me proposer pile le parfait
mélange entre des choses entre des
choses qui pour elle qui sera en mesure
de nous plaire et et en plus qui sera en
mesure de devenir finalement bien que
très différents avec des ingrédients
très différents mais finalement qui vont
constituer quelque chose de cohérent
on a donc cette linéarité qui vont de
cette personnalisation aussi et en ça on
peut peut-être plus faire le parallèle
avec le zapping dans son sens le plus le
plus commun c'est-à-dire le zapping
télévisuel on passe d'une chaise à une
chaîne à une autre sans forcément être
s'être abonnés à la chaîne vous voilà on
passe de l'un à deux ainsi de suite
jusqu'à ce qu'on tombe éventuellement
show quelque chose qu'on reste un petit
peu plus de temps que passe à une autre
chaîne stock c'est un peu ça il y a une
forme de passivité aussi vis-à-vis de
vis-à-vis de ça et de linéarité on va
pas choisir le contenu qu'on va
consommer comme youtube par exemple on
va choisir
le compte doit choisir la vidéo qu'on va
regarder ou instagram on va choisir les
comptes auxquels on à s'abonner et puis
devront apparaître que les éléments qui
viennent de ces contrats ce mode de
consommation non peut être mis en
parallèle avec le zapping c'est ce que
je dis mais d'ailleurs on parle de
zapping quand on parle notamment de
vraiment dire qu'on parle de de hockey
mais quel rapport à la colonisation
numérique alors je comprends pas ta
question cher thierry dubreuil
je viens tu précises la question je la
comprends pas le concept de connexion
numérique tels que tu le présenta je ne
comprends pas donc je continue mais je
voulais que tu me que tu reformuler la
question si elle dérange pas d'un oui
donc commandes notamment effectivement
on a une consommation zapping deux sets
de 7
tout ces éléments là mais on a également
un zapping aujourd'hui sur la vidéo à la
demande par exemple sur netflix ou en à
un happening permanent également entre
les différentes icônes jusqu'à choisir
où finalement les coucher parce qu'on
n'a pas trouvé le film finalement qu'on
voulait voir tic tac propose aussi
quelque chose de très différent par
rapport aux autres par rapport à
d'autres plateformes
c'est notamment la facilité de mise en
participation il suffit de réagir de se
filmer en train de réagir à une vidéo
virale de participer à un challenge qui
a mis en place par par un influenceur ou
quelconque et très vite on peut avoir
une viralité
et très vite on peut se mettre en avant
par le prisme justement de cet
algorithme qui va aller piocher un petit
peu partout des potentielles sources aux
intérêts et donc on va se trouver au
centre de la création par des moyens
très simples et encore une fois ça va
être très différenciée de twitter parce
qu'on sait que sur twitter par exemple
on a une polarisation
des débats et des créations de contenus
autour de contes déjà reconnu qui
regroupe des gens très connus qui
diffuse qui ont des milliers voire des
millions d'abonnés et donc du coup là on
va essayer en bas on va assister à une
dispersion des éléments qui va être
beaucoup plus d dispersion des éléments
et puis des éléments créatifs qui vont
être qu'ils vont être mises en place
alors dès lors on peut se poser une
question est ce que ces deux là alors
j'écris est close il fait pour pour un
peu posé cette question moment-là a dès
lors qu'on admire constamment et
répétitive et répétitivement avec
fascination ses contenus fréquemment
inutile et insipide fondamentalement 20
en eux mêmes on peut se poser la
question l'algorithme produit-il cette
nouvelle forme de diffusion médiatique
une forme d'art créée en cela en créant
une suprise sur une fixation fluide et
sensiblement cohérente d'image issus des
champs et des thématiques parfois très
distinctes un algorithme artistes qui
encourage les consommateurs à consommer
sans effort et alec et aux créateurs de
créer sans difficulté donc est-ce qu'il
n'y aurait pas un nouveau support
artistique et l'algorithme lui-même par
sa capacité de proposer une cohérence
comme ça de créer justement quelque
chose qui aurait à voir avec une forme
de nouvelles arts médiatiques alors
qu'on peut se poser la question
effectivement de est-ce que cet
algorithme proposé quelque chose
d'artistique alors par contre avec les
hauteurs de l'ago rythme des artistes me
semble un peu plus compliqué parce qu'il
faut savoir que l'entreprise tik tok
avance appel à l'entreprise de bike days
et en chine et notamment ils ont été
amenés à supprimer des postes créés par
des utilisateurs jugé trop moche trop
pauvres ou trop handicapé pour la
plateforme pas exactement l'esprit libre
penseurs artistes devant l'éternel et
qui ont également soutenu la censure
politique menée par la chine par le
gouvernement chinois
donc là je vous renverrai général
commentaires également une référence du
journal intercepte justement qui revient
sur 7 sur cette discrimination qui est
utilisé par par l'application
savoir que évidemment au delà de cette
censure autoritaire on peut avoir
également une forme d'autocensure ou de
censure plus douce souple un peu de soft
power qui par la sélection par la finale
va favoriser des gens avec un physique
plutôt agréable à l'oeil qui va
favoriser des certains cadres de vie
certaines ethnies éventuellement aussi
et qui va du coup mettre de côté
certaines personnalités
certains physique certains cadres de vie
pour au final bien vous faire comprendre
en tant qu'utilisateur en tant
qu'individu que des 27 partis pas partie
des des canons de beauté des stéréotypes
qui sont véhiculées par par la plate
forme d'une petite conclusion sur cet
article là également
aussi la boue rythme de tik tok il tombe
finalement conçu et personnalisé mais
plus important encore il a su automatisé
que léo est entièrement l'expérience de
consommation en ligne
vous n'avez pas à décider ce qui vous
intéresse il suffit pour vous de vous
abandonner à la plateforme donc encore
avec ses gestes très simples pour
pouvoir passer d'un continent à un autre
et du coup pour la plateforme de
s'informer sur ce que sur ce que vous
êtes et tik tok souhaite évidemment
cette attention et toute cette passivité
car couplée à une connaissance du coup
très fine
parce que extrêmement étoffé de ski cap
notre attrait c'est un terrain
évidemment idéal pour la publicité et
son immersion au sein de nos réflexes
d'appréciation du coup voilà pour le
dernier article alors une conclusion
brève vis-à-vis tacle après et je
prendrai éventuellement des questions ce
qui retient là qu'est ce qu'on peut
déduire un petit peu de tous ces
articles qu'on a vu l'a déjà c'est que
les algorithmes sont difficiles à rendre
intelligent encore une fois on l'a dit
et on l'a répété
l'intelligence artificielle ne peut se
mettre que très difficilement en
parallèle avec intelligence humaine et
donc elle en mesure de non seulement
répéter les biais de l'humain voir les
amplifier les rendre vrai à une échelle
encore plus encore plus importante
et en plus il est encore plus une
difficulté à rendre une intelligence
artificielle intelligentes quand cette
intelligence artificielle est fait à
dessein justement pour être
particulièrement pertinente pour
simplement d'une logique commerciale
[Musique]
pour ça justement pour accroître
l'engagement et pourrait plus
performants pour proposer de la
publicité
là on va voir que justement l'algorithme
et c'est quelque chose qui sait très
bien faire il est particulièrement
précis est capable
pour ce qui est de 7,2 cette tâche là
aussi du coup le danger ici sont le pas
tant l'artiste l'intelligence
artificielle en elle-même mais le fait
que la majorité de nos activités
numériques soient mises en mouvement par
des algorithmes principalement afin de
nous exploser de la meilleure manière
possible à la publicité et du coup aux
logiques une consommation cela
évidemment parfois au mépris des
considérations
qu'elle soit démocratique ou citoyenne
voilà donc voilà pour ce premier
exercice de live avec ces trois articles
différents donc alors j'ai retiré
vraiment ce n'est pas je sature emploi
de termes qui je crois que tu as un
vocabulaire un peu plus un peu plus
étoffé que le mien donc j'ai du mal à
capter toutes et tous que tu peux me
dire mon subjugation une subjugation par
rapport à quoi
je ne sais vraiment pas de l'alimenter
mais j'ai du mal à capter le sens de tes
questions si tu peux être juste un peu
plus clair pour moi parce que
[Musique]
oui
alors oui effectivement john terry wayne
ont du coup c'est une logique donc la
commande et son numérique effectivement
s'est créé par une logique basé sur
l'accumulation de données mais c'est
exactement ça c'est exactement ça rit et
notamment il ya beaucoup de
technologiste aujourd'hui donc on
appelle technologistes les gens qui qui
ont une une
une fois oui voilà ce sera exactement
donc là il dit comme si cette
rationalité et est capable de donner un
meilleur portrait de la réalité
exactement il ya justement cette énergie
donc ces gens qui ont confiance au
développement de la deûle à
l'intelligence artificielle et puis des
technologies et puis de fait de donner
un meilleur un meilleur un meilleur
souffle à la halle à la chose
technologique
ils disent que de toute façon on va
alors de l'intelligence artificielle on
va lui donner de plus en plus de données
on va amener à lui portait toujours
toujours plus et toujours plus
d'informations et que force de ces
informations il va être capable d'avoir
une analyse toujours plus fine de la
situation est donc d'être nécessairement
plus capable
alors pour le premier article d'avoir
une vraie propension à ne pas trop
mettre en avant des fausses informations
ou à engager des unités peu de l'effet
boule de neige sur les effets très très
problématique pour le local du deuxième
article rsa est d'oublier un petit peu d
éléments ou de capter des interruptions
d'un rêve d'un événement pour pour les
gens qui ont des problématiques sur tel
ou tel à tel ou tel moment de leur vie
ou pour le troisième est capable
effectivement de capter l'attention
mais peut-être que cela sert un but un
petit peu plus un peu plus un peu plus
sain que celui de l'accumulation de
données sur les sur les utilisateurs
et puis deux
surtout de créer un écrin incroyable
pour la publicité
voilà voilà voilà
j'espère que j'ai répondu à ta question
et que j'ai été assez clair ok et bien
gérée mears a très bien géré à dire
s'agirait dire ça alors oui j'ai lu que
je le dise balkanisation
mais en fait je voyais pas le lien avec
avec tout ça mais je regarderai encore
un peu plus peut-être que le c'est moi
qui n'ai pas qui n'est pas assez bien
assez bien perçu merci à toi chérie
donc voilà bon c'était un premier arrêt
c'est un premier exercice
c'était moi j'ai trouvé ça plutôt plutôt
amusant j'ai vu pas mal de choses sur
lesquelles je suis un peu foiré aussi
mais c'est un s'est échouée pas faire et
donc et donc merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup aux gens qui étaient là c'était
c'était sympa évidemment cette vidéo
sera disponible en replay
donc n'hésitez pas à la partager ce qu
elle sera disponible généré couper
quelques trucs pour pour qu'elle soit un
petit peu plus courte peut-être et
qu'elle soit un peu plus un peu plus
durable et puis pour ceux qui la
regardent maintenant ou qui la regardent
qui regardent en replay je cherche pas
mal je cherche pas mal de éventuellement
un collaborateur une collaboratrice voir
des collaborateurs des collaboratrices
pour créer le genre de contenu parce
qu'effectivement c'est un peu qu'un peu
un peu pénible parfois apporter à porter
tout seul parce que ça prend du temps
simplement et que je bosse à côté donc
nous voilà menée en tout cas c'était
très plaisant à faire j'espère que ça
vous a plu
et puis on choisit à la prochaine en
espérant que en espérant que que l'on
pourra faire une une autre émission un
peu sympa je pense que d'ici peu je
mettrai sur facebook et sur et sur
youtube ou aussi un petit sondage
je retiendrai l'échelle il ya quelques
thématiques que j'aimerais bien aborder
et puis je mettrais un sondage sur
youtube sur voilà sur les différentes
sujet que j'aimerais bien abordé dans
l'est
dans l'est dans les jours à venir dans
les jours à venir dans les semaines à
venir on va être un peu plus un peu plus
un peu plus pessimiste quand même en
plus réaliste et surtout et donc voilà
si vous voulez me rejoindre s'écoule
hésitez pas à envoyer un message et si
vous voulez vous exprimer beaucoup sur
les sujets à venir et va écouter ci
n'est pas un monde informé par le petit
sondage que je mettrais que je mettrai
en place
en tout cas merci beaucoup je vous
souhaite une très bonne journée à plus
je vous remercie encore une fois aux
quelques personnes qui étaient là
d'avoir d'avoir suivi ce live
et puis on se dit on se dit à très
bientôt